[Music]
i'm so honored to be here and share with
you guys thanks so much for coming out
tonight
[Music]
maybe where you're supposed to be
save the camp within the crowd
[Music]
but you're looking for a reason to break
free
seems like you want to scream but your
voice are never too loud
[Music]
it's what is
need we all need we don't need we all
need a little desperation
can i have can i have can i have can i
have a little desperation
[Music]
do you want do you want do you want do
you want a little inspiration
everyone everyone everyone
really needs a little desperation
and
maybe it cost you everything
but you're looking all around and the
only one left is you
and now the clock is in full swing
at the finish line
you can say you never knew
you gotta let it go
so much worse if you don't try now
you gotta let it show
take a chance take
[Music]
can i have can i have can i have can i
have a little inspiration
do you want do you want a little
inspiration
does everyone
really need
don't you ever give up go just a little
longer just a little longer
hey love don't you ever give up go just
a little stronger
you're gonna make it through the stormy
weather and one day it's gonna get
better don't you ever give up go just a
little longer
cause we all need a little desperation
thank you